Das, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war so ein kleiner Appetizer, das soll alle jetzigen Zweitligisten so richtig scharf darauf machen, man könnte sagen, es soll sie Heiden geil machen, darauf aufzusteigen, denn so kann das nämlich klingen. So war das im letzten Jahr beim ersten FC Heidenheim und auch zwei bis drei Vereine werden sie am Ende dieser Saison auch geschafft haben, am Ende dieser Zweitligasaison der Männer und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen in der Ligatur. Letztes Jahr haben wir –nee, nicht letztes Jahr, letzte Woche –haben wir dieses Format wieder aus dem Sommerschlaf aufgeweckt mit dem Blick auf die europäischen Top-Ligen der Männer. Heute wollen wir auf die zweite Bundesliga der Männer blicken und wir machen das im inzwischen etablierten Format mit drei Gästen, die einfach ein bisschen was zu ihren Vereinen erzählen. Und da begrüße ich zum einen Pike vom Kiel Podcast 1912 FM. Hallo Pike, schön, dass du da bist. Dann ist Sonja Riegel hier. Ihr kennt sie von Früff natürlich. Und heute können wir endlich mal über wen Wiesbaden sprechen. Da haben wir beide schon länger drauf gewartet. Hallo Sonja.
Der ja auch so ein bisschen ein gutes Licht wirft auf den neuen Sportdirektor Benjamin Weber. Also Tabakovitsch ist jetzt kein 18-jähriges Talent. Der ist 29, glaube ich, und kommt von Austria, Wien. Also da hätten auch andere darauf aufmerksam werden können. Jetzt hatten wir sehr, sehr viel Umbruch im Kader mit sehr vielen Abgängen und eben auch sehr vielen Neuzugängen. Was würdest du denn sagen, kennzeichnet diese erste, richtige Transferperiode von Benjamin Weber, außer dass er diesen Tabakovitsch, die er durchgezogen hat, obwohl sein Handyakku zwischendurch leer gegangen ist, ihn wohl ein bisschen in den Schwitzen gebracht hat?
Ja, das fand ich auch ganz, ganz lustig. Ich glaube, der Hauptpunkt ist wirklich, was Hertha wichtig war, war, dass es möglichst alle Spieler sind, die sich voll und ganz mit dem Verein auch identifizieren können, die sich da reinwerfen und auch mit Leidenschaft vorangehen, weil man zu oft in den letzten Jahren irgendwie gesagt hat, man kauft Spieler mit Mentalität, aber dann irgendwie es dann doch relativ schnell irgendwie eingeknickt ist, so in dem Sinne. Also Ivan Szunyuc war zum Beispiel so jemand, der wurde eben genau geholt mit, der ist einer, der ist eklig, der ist dreckig auf dem Platz, der kämpft dann, aber dann kommt er bei dem ersten Dardai-Training schon nicht mehr klar und lässt sich irgendwie hängen. Wilfried Congar hat sich irgendwie dann doch enttäuschend oft im Spiel hängen lassen. Und ich glaube, was den Leuten in der Geschäftsstelle wichtig war, war, dass es Spieler sind, die sich voll und ganz identifizieren können, worum es für Hertha geht. Und das ist nicht unbedingt direkt der Aufstieg, sondern das ist daran, jetzt sportlich eine gewisse Identität auch zu entwickeln, unter Dardai fleißig zu sein. Das ist immer sein Lieblingswort. Er will eine fleißige Mannschaft und die Mannschaft, die er zum Ende der Bundesliga vorgefunden hat, war nicht fleißig. Die neue Mannschaft ist es, das lobt er immer wieder. Und das ist so ein Punkt plus. Man muss jetzt auch wieder mehr mit dem Ball selber machen. Man weiß einfach, dass man häufig in eine Favoritenrolle rückt. Das heißt, auch eine gewisse Kreativität in den Kader geholt. Mit Dudziak, mit Karbovnik. Das sind solche Spieler, die man da nennen kann. Und das würde ich so erwähnen. Einfach auch eine gewisse Achse zu schaffen, auf die man sich verlassen kann über ein Jahr hinaus. Da ist Toni Leist ein Faktor, da ist auch Andreas Buchalakis, den man noch am vorletzten Transfertag geholt hat aus Pireus. Der war mal Kapitän bei Olympiakos Pireus vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, vor zwei, drei Jahren. Der ist sofort im Mittelfeld ein Führungsspieler. Auch Fabian Reese ist jemand, der gerne an diesem Team Verantwortung übernimmt. Das ist etwas, wo man eine Achse mit Marius Gersbeck aufbauen wollte. Das hat aus bekannten Gründen nicht ganz geklappt. Aber da hat man ein gewisses Führungsvakuum, das bei Hertha die letzten Jahre war. Seitdem man einen Sommer Spieler wie Ibiscevic und Skjelbrit verloren hat, hat man versucht, das mit Spielern aufzufüllen, die gerne Verantwortung übernehmen und die nicht unter dem Druck der Verantwortung schwächer werden. Bei Hertha war es oft so, dass sobald jemand die Kapitänsbinde angezogen hat, war er nur noch 80 Prozent so gut wie eigentlich. Toni Leissner ist eben genau das Gegenteil davon. Der blüht auch mit dieser Binde auf und der ist das gewohnt aus den letzten Jahren. Darunter sammeln sich dann auch mehrere weitere Führungsspieler, die gerne vorangehen. Das tut dem Verein ganz gut.
Das bringt mich zur letzten Frage, Benny. Wie ist die Stimmung im Umfeld? Beziehungsweise Sonja möchte noch etwas sagen.
Ich hoffe, ich nehme dir da nichts weg. Wenn ich es jetzt frage, ob es im Umfeld ist, ist es etwas anderes. Ich wollte mal fragen, wie du den Trainer wahrnimmst. Ich wollte jetzt nicht sagen, wie du Dardai wahrnimmst. Sonst können wir über ganz viele verschiedene Dinge reden, um da mal bei den schlechten Witzen einfach mitzumachen. Nein, wie du Paul Dardai wahrnimmst. Was ich so von ihm mitbekommen habe, ich glaube, es war nach dem Fürth-Spiel, da hat er sich bei Sky hingestellt. Im Interview fand ich ihn irgendwie arg Drama-Queen. Mit seinem, wir waren gar nicht so schlecht, wie ihr alle gesagt habt. Wir haben es eben schon besprochen, was Hertha die ersten Spiele so gebracht hat. Ich kann gerade von dem Wiesbaden-Spiel sagen, da passte noch nicht viel zusammen. Da hätte er einfach sagen können, ihr kennt ja alle die Vorgeschichte, der Kader steht noch nicht so. Da wir Tabakovic jetzt hatten, der kam gegen Wiesbaden das erste Mal rein und hat ja schon angedeutet, was da gehen kann mit einem Latten-Treffer, der auch so gut das Siegthof von Hertha hätte sein können. Aber dass Erich dann da hinstellt und irgendwie so, da hat er versucht so Statistiken zu bemühen, die ich gar nicht so richtig nachvollziehen konnte. Das fand ich eine einigermaßen seltsame Reaktion. Wenn du jetzt auch noch was sagst, dass Erdan schon wieder sagt, wenn da irgendetwas nicht passt, dann trete ich zurück. Das ist ja sowieso so ein bisschen sein Kern. Das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass er das so formuliert.
Ich bin nur der kleine Pahl. Ich kann auch wieder die U23 trainieren.
Ja, so ist es ja unterhaltsam für uns. Aber jetzt hätte ich gerne mal deine Sicht dazu.
Gute Frage. Ich nehme ihn auch etwas dünnhäutig wahr, muss ich sagen. Also es war bei Hertha oft so, dass Dardai eigentlich immer sehr locker war und immer einen Spruch auf den Lippen hatte. Also hat er irgendwie dann einen Finger an, mal seine Spieler mit Tieren zu vergleichen. Oder keine Ahnung, dass er nach einer Pressekonferenz in Hoffenheim erstmal den besten Milchreis seines Lebens gelobt hat. Und solche Sachen. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er selber –er hat ja auch schon gesagt, er nimmt das teilweise als Mobbing wahr, was passiert in den Medien und sowas, was ich gar nicht so extrem finde. Weil es ist mehr oder weniger eigentlich Springer, mit denen er sich anlegt. Und es sind nicht die Medien so, sondern es ist ein Medienhaus, mit dem er nicht ganz konform geht. Weil ich finde nicht, dass man in den anderen Medien gelesen hat, dass Hertha als Aufstiegsfavorit sofort gesprochen wird. Es ist eher so ein erweiterten Kreis. Und Dardai behauptet, dass alle gesagt hätten, dass Hertha sofort aufsteigen müsste. Und er hat immer gesagt, es wird schwer. Und dabei haben eigentlich die meisten, auch bei den Fans, die Erwartung nicht. Wir steigen sofort wieder auf, weil man genau weiß, dass es ganz anders war. Deswegen nehme ich ihn auf jeden Fall dünnhäutig wahr. Er hat dann auch wieder Tage, wo er sehr locker ist. Es ist so ein bisschen hin und her. Man merkt einfach, manche Themen nerven ihn sehr. Das ist immer mit seinen Söhnen. Weil er nicht will, dass sie als seine Söhne betitelt werden, sondern dass auch gesagt wird, hier, das ist Marthorn Dardai, das ist Palko Dardai, das ist Bence Dardai und nicht, dass gesagt wird, ihr Sohn Bence, ihr Sohn Marthorn, ihr Sohn Palko. Das ist ihm wichtig, damit die nicht einfach wie ein Spieler beschrieben werden, als wäre es ein Fabian Rehse, als wäre es ein Smile, Préviac, wie auch immer. Und da reagiert er dann gerne mal sehr dünnhäutig. Und ich finde, wo ich dir auch recht gebe, ich war auch verblüfft von diesem Sky-Interview, weil ich fand das Hertha spielerisch auch gegen Düsseldorf und gegen Wiesbaden. Da waren sie ja defensiv ganz gut, aber offensiv war das jetzt auch wirklich nicht spektakulär. Also da hat man sich nicht so viel herausgespielt. Aber ich glaube, dass er, er will halt auch nicht diesen Stempel als Defensiv-Trainer haben, weil er, glaube ich, dieses Jahr auch offensiver spielen will. Also er spricht gerne dann auf einmal davon, dass er so den Traum hat von einer Mannschaft mit vollen fluiden Positionen in der Offensive. Hat dann von einem U17-Turnier, wo er mal Trainer war, bei Hertha rezitiert, wo er meinte, er hätten alle in der D4-5-Offensivspieler, hätten alle total fluide mal von rechts ins Zentrum, dann nach links und so. Und nur die Verteidiger hatten wirklich klare Positionen. Und dass er sich das auch langfristig für Hertha wünschen würde. Und er hat ja auch schon in der früheren Zeit mal davon gesprochen, dass er als Hertha so ein neues Ajax gerne machen will. Und ich glaube, deswegen sind diese Punkte. Er will nicht als Defensivtrainer abgestempelt werden. Und er will nicht als Vater von drei Spielern abgestempelt werden. Und ich glaube, sobald es in diese Themen geht, wird er dann etwas sensibler und dann auch etwas aggressiver nach außen oder etwas klarer und stellt sich dann ganz klar vor die Mannschaft, vor den Verein und dann lieber eine Spur Hertha als eine Spur Schwächer, um da vielleicht mal so ein bisschen manche zu bremsen in der Berichterstattung. Weil er das, ja, es wirkt schon teilweise wie ein Clinch auch zwischen Hertha und der Bild, muss man einfach auch so sagen.
Also, und wenn was passt zu Pardadai, dann ja wohl, wenn eine Spur Hertha. Du hast den einfach so nebenher gemacht. Ich habe den jetzt einfach nur verwertet.
Ich habe in deinem Gesichtsausdruck gesehen, was ich gesagt habe.
Ja, das ist der Nachteil von Video. Ihr wusstet alle, was kommt. Allerletzte Frage, wir haben es schon ein bisschen überzogen, aber ich kann es nicht weglassen. Die Stimmung im Umfeld, denn habe ich das richtig gehört, Dauerkartenrekord oder zumindest sehr, sehr viele Dauerkarten verkauft. Und das ja auch schon quasi, als es schlecht lief. Also man hat jetzt nicht nur gewartet auf das 5-0 gegen Fürth und dann haben alle gesagt, ah, jetzt ist Hertha gut, sondern es scheint mir, das, was wir alles als sehr großes Drama wahrgenommen haben, von außen und auch als die Möglichkeit, vielleicht rutscht Hertha sogar durch in die dritte Liga. Also zumindest hat es jetzt nicht die Fans daran gehindert, Tickets zu kaufen.
Also der Zuschausschnitt liegt bei fast 40.000, obwohl die Gegner bisher Fürth, Braunschweig und Wien-Wiesbaden waren. Und da noch kein Schalke, kein Magdeburg, kein Rostock, kein St. Pauli dabei war. Oder der HSV, wo wahrscheinlich noch weitaus mehr kommen werden. Ich glaube einfach, dass viele sich mit diesem Berliner Weg sehr gut identifizieren können. Bei Hertha träumt man immer von dieser, oder denkt gerne zurück an diese Generation mit Kevin Prinz, Boateng, Patrick Ebert und Co. Das waren Leute, mit denen man sich komplett identifizieren kann. Das waren die Berliner Straßenkids, die anders Fußball gespielt haben, ein bisschen erfrischend waren für die Mannschaft. Und jetzt hat man wieder diesen Berliner Weg mit vielen jungen Spielern im Kader. Ich glaube, ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, es waren 11, 12 oder 13 Spieler, die unter 23 sind, die jetzt schon gespielt haben in diese Zeit. Nicht alle aus der eigenen Jugend, aber sehr viele Junge. Man unterstützt diese Mannschaft auch sehr gerne, weil man weiß, die brauchen auch die Fans. Und die kämpfen auch für diese Fans. Die haben richtig Bock drauf. Robert Quasi-Groch, die eigentliche Nummer 2, der durfte jetzt gegen Braunschweig spielen, weil Tjag Ernst einen Magen-Darm-Infekt hatte. Der hat nach dem Spiel geweint, weil er so glücklich war, dass er im Olympiastadion mal ein Spiel spielen durfte. Ich glaube, das sind die Szenen, die dann komplett emotionalisieren und auch dafür sorgen, dass die Identifikation zwischen Mannschaft und Fans, wonach sie die Fans jahrelang gesehen haben, eine Mannschaft, mit der sie sich identifizieren können und die nicht wieder nächstes Jahr alle weggehen wollen, das ist ein Faktor, der eine große Rolle spielt. Dann weiß man auch um diese schwierige finanzielle Lage und will diesen Verein an allen möglichen Punkten unterstützen. Das ist, glaube ich, dann auch noch mal ein Faktor, der eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, die Hertha-Fans waren schon immer da, wenn man sie gebraucht hat. Den Fans konnte man eigentlich nie etwas vorwerfen. Klar kann man mal diskutieren, ob es jetzt hilfreich ist, knapp 20-Jährigen die Trikots abzunehmen nach einem verlorenen Derby. Aber mit solchen Ausnahmen, ansonsten stabile Kurve, würde ich sagen, auch im ganzen Engagement, was über den Fußball hinausgeht. Also das CSA, die Fans werden es weitermachen, die Aktionen für Obdachlose usw. Selbst wenn der Verein das jetzt nicht mehr machen kann. Ihr drei, irgendwie könnte ich noch lange mit euch sprechen. Eigentlich wollte ich mit euch auch noch allgemein über die Liga sprechen. Aber das stecken wir uns jetzt einfach, weil wir haben so viel gelernt. Aber ich bin sehr, sehr dankbar, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich habe sehr aufmerksam vorhin in Piekes Augen geforscht, bei jeder Erwähnung von Fabian Reese. Aber ich habe da keinen großen Schmerz erkannt. Also ich glaube, du bist darüberhin weggekommen.
Tatsächlich war er ein Spieler, der ersetzbar war. Zumindestens von seiner Effektivität. Er war ein Spieler, der immer, wie Benni auch meinte, der ackert, der zieht die Abwehr auf sich, der rennt, egal wie viele Minuten, egal wie doll man zurück lag. Der hat immer alles gegeben. Und auch schon bei Kiel so die kleinen Dinge im Spiel direkt gefeiert, immer wieder die Kurve angeheizt. Aber er hat die meisten Flanken geschlagen, aber auch davon sehr wenig an Mann gebracht.
Ja, die meisten Flanken, es muss kein Qualitätssiege sein.
Genau.
Pike, da hast du dich jetzt nochmal mit einer letzten Einschätzung quasi selbst nochmal verabschiedet. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Alle, die sagen, ey, das war ja viel zu wenig zu Kiel, ja, dann hört mal 1912 FM, da kann man dich ja auch hören. Danke, dass du hier warst.
Danke für die Einladung.
Und danke, ich freue mich sehr, Sonja, dass wir jetzt auch über den Wiesbaden gesprochen haben. Wenn wir es auch noch irgendwann schaffen, über den ESC zu sprechen, dann haben wir, glaube ich, sobald alle Themen abgedeckt sind, bei denen du volle Kompetenz ausdrehst. Danke dir, Sonja, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ja, danke dir. Dann die Sonderfolge Rasenfunk meets ESC.
Ja, eigentlich zusammen mit Tobias Escher müsste man schon mal –eigentlich ist das ein Livestream. Seien wir ehrlich, das ist ein Livestream. Aber mal gucken.
Ja, Livestream ist schwierig, aber ich arbeite da ja auch immer.
Ach ja, stimmt, genau.
Wir können den nicht zusammen gucken oder so. Wir könnten irgendwie so real live gucken.
Ob das im real life funktioniert, weiß ich nicht. Aber ja, stimmt, du bist natürlich da immer unterwegs. Auf bleistiftrocker.de heißt deine Seite, wo man all die Texte dazu lesen kann. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Ist ja überhaupt nicht meine Musik, was so beim ESC läuft, außer irgendwelche Norweger Schickmieder-Metal-Bands. Dann bin ich auch mit dabei. Aber ich habe schon so manches bei dir gelesen. Einfach nur, weil es mich dann doch interessiert hat. Also sehr schöne Texte.
Stichwort Lesen vielleicht noch, weil du es vorhin in der Einleitung nicht gesagt hast. hessenschau.de gibt es natürlich von mir Berichte über den SVB in Wiesbaden. Also du hast jetzt nicht gesagt, wo das herkommt, dass ich mich für den Verein beschäftige. Aber das ist hauptsächlich für den HR.
Ja, stimmt, sehr gut. Ach, das ist so schön. Ich muss meinen Job ja gar nicht machen. Ihr übernehmt das schon für mich. Und ihr macht auch für mich die Wortspiele, die ich dann nur noch aufnehmen muss. Das hat mir Benjamin Zurmühl in diesem Fall gemacht. Danke dir, Benni, dass du mal wieder hier warst. War sehr interessant, mit dir über HTA BSC zu sprechen. Also, ich habe damit keine Probleme. Und so wie ich die Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und –Hörer kenne, wird das für die auch in Ordnung gewesen sein. Herzlichen Dank euch dreien. Und herzlichen Dank euch da draußen für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Im Rasenfunk haben wir wahnsinnig viele Folgen veröffentlicht. Also, ihr könnt ja was hören zur Frauen-Bundesliga, zur Männer-Bundesliga, zum europäischen Fußball. Klickt euch einfach mal auf rasenfunk.de und dann durch die Sendung. Wenn ihr da nichts findet, was euch nicht ein bisschen interessiert, dann seid ihr das Problem und nicht der Rasenfunk. So offensiv kann ich das jetzt formulieren. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.